I am
only in contact with the members.
Agujjim's
knee rotation is also useless.
I am
Hwang Jung-min.
Hwang Jung-min's
acting is a little bit realistic. I think you will
try and film me to understand me completely, so
I
know what the robot's favorite food is. If
it is far away,  I know what it
is, Munchkin is good at English, so
I want to experience it. I
'll bring Heeseung's absolute pitch, English, and Nikki's dance.
1 2 3 Actually, he's cool no matter what he does, so there's nothing
I
can't make because YouTube content is trending again.
But secretly, Sunghoon is good at design.  They say
I only have the
ability to grant one wish, so even though I have 100 wishes,
I
still remember when I called the Teddy member, but the
7 of us are gathered in a circle like this and
are doing this for us in the world.
That
feeling is really day and night.  This has changed. I
think everyone will age gracefully. I
ate pork today, stir-fried pork. I
want to go to the future. The future will come anyway. I
can't go back to the past, so I went to bed at 12 o'clock
[Music]